la visita del Rey Carlos III es
definitivamente bien importante y
significativo de su siguiente su segunda
parada en esta gira de reconocimiento
por las regiones británicas ya ha
saludado a las multitudes de personas
que han ido hasta el Palacio de
Hillsboro a saludarlo a la reina
consorte a presentarle de manera
personal sus sentidos mensajes de
condolencia Carlos se reunirá con los
líderes políticos y religiosos de
Irlanda del Norte y llega como lo
mencionas en una coyuntura política bien
compleja no hay un gobierno regional
formado después de hace meses El Triunfo
histórico de los republicanos del
chinfeng todavía no se han podido poner
de acuerdo a los partidos para formar
ese gobierno el partido nacionalista
democrático unionista de Up ha dicho que
no formará ese gobierno hasta que se
renegocie el protocolo de Irlanda del
Norte tras el brexit pero esa no es una
potestad que tiene el gobierno británico
sino la Unión Europea entre tanto Los
líderes políticos han dicho que en medio
de este luto nacional las diferencias
políticas se dejarán a un lado pero por
supuesto es una tensión que se siente en
el ambiente y como lo mencionaba hace el
Rey Carlos asistirá esta tarde a un
nuevo tributo religioso que se realizará
en honor a la Reina Isabel II en la
catedral de sanana en belfast la capital
de Irlanda del Norte